For this programming exercise, you just needed to add a
new layer onto our code, and that was the cord translayer.
I'll pass at the y variable, and I'll set that
y equal to square root, which is the function we'll use
to transform the y axis. With this plot, it's much
easier to see the distribution of friend count, conditional, and age.
For example, we can see thresholds of friend count above
which there are very few users. Now, you might have noticed
I went back from geom_jitter to geom_point. If we wanted to
also add jitter to the points, we'd have to use a bit
more elaborate syntax to specify that we only want to jitter the
ages. We also need to be careful since some people have a
friend count of 0. If we add noise to 0 friend counts,
we might end up with negative numbers for some of our friend
counts and those square roots would be imaginary, okay. So to make
this adjustment I'm going to set the position parameter equal to position
jitter and then I'll pass it a minimum height of 0. This
is a bit more advanced in terms of syntax but it prevents us
from having that warning message and
getting negative friend counts over here. Remember
that jitter can add positive or negative noise to each of our points.